>> Tucker: THIS ISN'T JUST A
NEWS PROGRAM.
THERE'S A GAME SHOW COMPONENT.
IT'S CALLED "FINAL EXAM."
WE DON'T JUST IF YOU WILL
PEOPLE OFF THE STREET COMPETE.
WE FIND ACTUAL NEWS
PROFESSIONALS, PEOPLE WHO
WATCH THE NEWS FOR A LIVING,
TO DETERMINE WHO'S BEEN PAYING
THE CLOSEST ATTENTION TO WHAT
HAS BEEN HAPPENING IN THE
WORLD THIS WEEK'S CONTESTANTS
ARE BOTH COHOSTS OF
"OUTNUMBERED."
KAILEY MCNANEY -- I'VE GOTTEN
INSIDE TIPS ON WHO MIGHT HAVE
THE ADVANTAGE BUT --
>> EMILY.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT GOING TO
REVEAL THOSE.
>> I HAVE THE REFLEXES OF A
SLOTH SO.
>> Tucker: I CAN SAY
SINCERELY I'M ROOTING FOR YOU
BOTH.
YOU KNOW THE RULES.
I'M JUST GOING TO REPEAT THEM
JUST IN CASE YOU HAVE
FORGOTTEN.
HANDS ON BUZZERS.
I ASK THE QUESTIONS.
THEY'RE ALL THE MULTIPLE
CHOICE.
THE FIRST PERSON TO BUZZ IN
GETS TO ANSWER.
ALL POSSIBLE ANSWERS OR FOR
ANSWERING.
GET IT WRONG, YOU LOSE A
POINT.
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> READY TO GO.
>> Tucker: THIS IS AN
AMAZING STORY.
I KNOW YOU'LL KNOW THE ANSWER.
A MASSACHUSETTS WOMAN
PROTESTING AN EVICTION HAS
BEEN CHARGED WITH ASSAULT AND
BATTERY FOR ATTACKING THE
POLICE IN A VERY UNUSUAL WAY.
WHAT WEAPON DID SHE USE?
WAS IT, A, A FERRET, B,
VENOMOUS SNAKES OR, C A SWARM
OF BEES.
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH A, A
FERRET.
THAT WOULD BE FUN!
>> Tucker: THAT'S A
TRADITIONAL WEAPON OF EEES --
EVICTEES?
>> SHE UNLEASHED A SWARM OF
BEES ON SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES.
THEY SAY SHE SMASHED A LID
OVER TO AGITATE THE BEES AND
MAKE THEM MORE AGGRESSIVE.
>> Tucker: WOW!
BEES, NOT THE FERRET.
I'M PRO-POLICE BUT I'M KIND OF
IMPRESSED.
BEES.
YOU NEVER HEAR THAT.
OK, TAKE A LOOK AT THE PICTURE
OF YOUR SCREEN.
IT'S AN EXTREME CLOSE UP OF A
BUG'S FACE.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT KIND OF
BUG IS IT?
A, A BED BUG?
B, ANT?
C, BLACK HORNED BEETLE?
>> IT IS AN ANT!
I SAW THIS.
IT'S TERRIFYING!
>> Tucker: OK.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF YOU'RE
CORRECT.
THAT'S YOUR GUESS.
HERE'S THE ANSWER.
>> WE'RE ABOUT TO SHOW YOU
SOMETHING THAT WILL HAUNT YOUR
DREAMS.
>> IT'S A CLOSE UP OF A FACE
THAT BORDERS ON DEMONIC.
LOOK AT IT.
IT HAS ANGRY RED EYES.
>> IT'S IMPRESSIVE.
>> YOU'RE DOING GREAT.
YOU'RE DOING GREAT.
>> Tucker: IT WAS AN ANT.
WE MOVE ONTO QUESTION THREE.
CONGRATULATIONS, BY THE WAY.
HERE IS THAT QUESTION, EVERY
OCTOBER HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
FLOCK TO A PLACE CALLED
CASTERLY, BELGIUM, FOR A VERY
DIFFERENT OF RACE.
PARTICIPANTS DRESS IN
HALLOWEEN COSTUMES AND PADDLE
ACROSS A LAKE IN BOATS MADE OF
WHAT?
A, PUMPKINS, B, PLASTIC
BOTTLES, C, RUBBER DUCKS?
EMILY?
>> GUESSING C, RUBBER DUCKS.
>> Tucker: THAT WHO HAVE
BEEN MY GUESS, TOO.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHETHER THAT'S
CORRECT OR NOT BUT WE'LL FIND
OUT.
IS IT BOATS OF RUBBER DUCKS?
>> CHECK OUT THIS ANNUAL
BELGIUM HALLOWEEN TRADITION.
>> I KNEW THERE WAS A RUBBER
DUCK EVENT SOMEWHERE.
>> Tucker: I WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT RUBBER DUCK, TOO, BUT
IT'S A MASSIVE PUMPKIN.
THIS IS A PRINCE HARRY
QUESTION.
PRINCE HARRY IS RELEASING A
TELL-ALL MEMOIR DESCRIBED AS
EMOTIONALLY POWERFUL AND
REMARKABLY PERSONAL ABOUT HIS
LIFE IN THE PUBLIC EYE.
THE NAME OF THE BOOK HAS JUST
BEEN REVEALED.
IS IT, A, GINGER AND
MISERABLE, MY WIFE AS A ROYAL
SELLOUT.
IS IT, B, MY CRAZED
NARCISSISTIC WIFE IS A
NIGHTMARE?
IS IT, C, SPARE?
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH C.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T THINK
IT'S MY CRAZED NARCISSISTIC
WIFE IS A NIGHTMARE?
YOU THINK IT'S SPARE?
>> THAT'S THE TRUE ONE.
>> Tucker: MORE ACCURATE.
OK.
LET'S FIND OUT IF YOU'RE
CORRECT.
IS IT SPARE?
>> WE'RE GETTING THE FIRST
LOOK OF THE COVER OF PRINCE
HARRY'S HIGHLY-ANTICIPATED
MEMOIR TITLED "SPARE."
THE TITLE WAS TAKEN FROM AIR
AND SPARE, NOT THE HARRY SPOT
IN THE ROYAL LINE OF
SUCCESSION AT ALL.
THE TELL ALL MEMOIR WILL HIT
SHELVES JANUARY 10th.
>> Tucker: SPARE.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
I PREFER B BUT WE DON'T MAKE
THE RULES HERE.
FINAL QUESTION, WE'RE GOING TO
END ON AN ANIMAL AS WE ALWAYS
DO.
HERE IS THE QUESTION, WHICH
U.S. CITY IS SO OVERRUN WITH
FILTHY VERMIN THAT CITY HAS
NOW BEEN CALLED AMERICA'S
RATTIEST CITY?
A, BALTIMORE?
B, LOS ANGELES?
C, CHICAGO?
EMILY?
>> C, CHICAGO!
>> Tucker: C, CHICAGO.
THE RATTIEST CITY IS THAT
CORRECT?
>> PEST CONTROL COMPANY ORKIN
SAYS THE WINDY CITY IS THE RAT
CAPITAL OF THE U.S.
CHICAGO HAS TOPPED THE LIST
FOR THE PAST EIGHT YEARS.
>> I WAS SURPRISED.
I LITERALLY SEE RATS EVERY DAY
I WAS WALKING OUT WHEN I WAS
THERE.
>> Tucker: AMAZING.
YOU GOT THAT CORRECT.
NOW, WE FIND OURSELVES
UNUSUALLY IN A TIE.
>> THAT MAKES SENSE!
>> Tucker: IT MAKES SENSE
BECAUSE YOU WENT FROM NEGATIVE
ONE ON A TWO-POINT QUESTION SO
WE'RE GOING TO DO TO OUR
TRADITIONAL TIEBREAKING
QUESTIONS, NOT MULTIPLE
CHOICE.
IT'S A VERY SIMPLE QUESTION.
ALMOST NOBODY KNOWS THE
ANSWER.
I'M GOING TO THROW IT TO YOU.
ARE YOU READY?
WHAT IS THE CAPITAL OF CANADA?
>> OTTAWA.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK
THAT'S RIGHT.
LET ME CHECK.
YES!
OUR JUDGES ARE SAYING THE
CAPITAL OF CANADA, WHICH IS A
COUNTRY, IS OTTAWA!
AMAZING!
YOU'RE ONE IN A MILLION!
I LOVE IT!
OK.
THAT A REMARKABLE COMEBACK BY
EMILY.
YOU GET OUR PATENTED
FETTERNECK MUG WHICH
HIGHLIGHTS THE GROWTH ON THE
BACK OF JOHN FETTERMAN'S NECK.
ENJOY YOUR COFFEE IN THAT.
>> I'M GIVING THIS TO HER
BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T HAVE ONE
YET AND I LOVE YOU.
YOU'RE MY COHOST.
WE ARE A TEAM.
SO IT'S YOUR MUG.
>> THANK YOU, EMILY.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE PASSING
THE GOITER LOVE TO A FRIEND.
THAT'S FRIENDSHIP.
WE APPRECIATE THAT HERE.
THANK YOU, BOTH.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK Y